[Music]
what's going on everyone so so I like to
keep things pretty casual so I'm gonna
talk to Jake but I want to get everyone
else involved so my twitter handle is
the sampar so if you guys have any
questions or want me to ask anything or
bring up anything tweet at me at any
point and I'll have my phone right here
but basically we've worked with movement
in the past before because we are huge
fans and I've known Jake for a little
while now and typically at hustle con we
get a lot of entrepreneurs who are
silicon valley-based
which means they tend to raise a whole
lot of money but what interested us with
movement and Jake's story is that this
company is only five years old and
they're tracking to do 100 million in
revenue this year in 2018 and that's
what that that's what taking zero
funding him and his team own 100% of the
business and what they've done is really
amazing and so today we're gonna talk
talk a little bit about how the company
started but also why they've taken
decided to take the bootstrap method
versus raising funding so Jake thanks
for coming here can you uh you know what
what what impressive what impressive
stats that I miss when introducing you
because I know there's so many yeah I
mean we're so yeah on track to do a
hundred million this year we have 35
employees in-house which is a pretty
lean team to your point we haven't
raised any capital we launched on
IndieGoGo even then I was in college I
was about 21 years old so the only money
I had was 18 months of interest-free
credit on my Chase credit card and
basically ran through that pretty quick
on samples in just kind of investing in
the initial samples and and camera
equipment everything that I needed to
really start the business and launch you
need to go go
and how many units have been sold since
you guys started over 1.5 million
you know it's crazy okay so what I want
to hear about is the very first month of
business so like you said you had a
little bit of you had some very small
personal line of credit yeah how much
was it it's $5,000 and you used that to
do what
so samples were a big portion of that we
we were very familiar with IndieGoGo and
Kickstarter back then it was still less
known and you know I dropped out of
college and at 19 so I spent my time
pretty much studying every single
Kickstarter and that went up in
understanding the do's and the don'ts
and why things worked and I could almost
predict when a campaign launched if it
was going to be successful or not so
first month was really
we bought a camera from Costco returned
it a week later spent 60 dollars on a
microphone on ebay returned it a week
later I mean pretty much it was his
bootstraps his bootstraps I can get but
really it was you know we designed the
watches in-house we work with the
manufacturers we found them on Hawley
Belva it was we were doing a little bit
of everything and the first month was
officially just on IndieGoGo and we
launched in June of 2013 and we didn't
have money to spend on Facebook or
Instagram or anything like that those
aren't even platforms that were well
known at the time to recoup your
investment for ads so for us it was
leveraging web sites like Reddit and
kind of just doing little growth hacks I
had people in the Philippines
upvoting my reddit posts to the number
one spot and it would generate 5,000
dollars in revenue I'd make a hundred
accounts on reddit post something about
my watch and different subreddits and
then use a proxy to change my IP address
and then upvote with this this wasn't
automated though this was oh this is
this is me this is fit like this is as
bootstrap sees you I mean this is
studying how to start an online business
without any capital okay so but you you
have this five grand you got the samples
and the samples you only had samples and
then you did the IndieGoGo campaign in
that part in 300k
yeah 300k so the whole concept is
basically show the samples tell the
story and if you can you know hit a
certain target goal which ours with
15,000 we ended up raising three hundred
thousand that the business would start
you have enough money to
place the initial production run and
then continue to buy him in my watches I
loved fashion and was just fascinated
with the watch industry there that was
one category that I couldn't really
afford many other products out there so
for me it was really about creating a
product and a brand that represented
something more than just a physical good
and watches was something that I really
liked from day one so you you use this
money to get samples which you use to
make your video then you hack reddit
which basically you just created a
hundred different accounts and posted
them all over the place I've been
commented about how much you love the
product it was me talking about how much
I love the product over and yeah got it
everyone's been there yeah we did it and
then with once you receive that 300k you
guys had found you how did you find your
suppliers so Alibaba
I don't have a good suggestion on how to
find the best manufacturer really for me
it was communication being one you know
we only had really one go to find to get
samples made because once you invest in
that like if the samples were [__]
you're screwed so for me it was reached
out to 30 or 40 different manufacturers
in Alibaba talk to them understand who
they worked with I think communication
is key because if they can't if there's
something being misinterpreted or missed
because the language barrier then
there's gonna be issues down the road
and I think people who work with the
United States a lot are just better at
communicating they have someone in their
office that can communicate better so
well and you're not like a watch
designer but you told me that you are
literally just like you like sketch is
that what you very little
they're little Photoshop self-taught
experience and it was a lot of kind of
so what it's an in-house service where
basically you go back and forth of them
they'll create a digital rendering so a
lot of times they'd miss and we go back
and forth back and forth but it was me
cutting out inspiration from different
brands or sketching different things and
a lot of back I mean it took eight
months to get samples now we're moving
much quicker with a designer in-house
but but it was you actually designing
the wat like literally drawing it out or
using Photoshop yeah we tried we went on
like up work and tried to find a
freelancer but it just it was easier for
we knew what we wanted and I felt like
we could illustrate that better and okay
so you get the 300 K from IndieGoGo in
like 30 days the campaign was 50 days
fifty day
you get that from hacking reddit what
did you so with that 300k how much went
to paying the supplier a good portion
basically was you know by the inventory
sold and then spend the rest of the
money to buy more inventory because if
this is gonna it was like do we either
take the money and call it quits or do
we you know reinvest that money in the
inventory essentially so we reinvested
in inventory saved a little bit for for
the website and then me and Cramer paid
ourselves my business partner paid
ourselves ten thousand dollars and then
half of that really went to the credit
card debt so how long was that Tang
Korean supposed to last you that was
really I was just focused on paying off
the credit card debt because I was
running out of time on that so were you
living at home I was living in Santa
Barbara where we officially started it
and then moved home with my parents and
I was on a fast track to get out of
there as quickly as possible so I was
which for the record your mom and your
brother work for you now my mom brother
cousin Kramer's brother on and sister so
[Laughter]
so you know we're the hustle were mostly
bootstrapped business and one thing I
think about when we first started was it
could it costs money to start [__] even
if you like even it doesn't matter if
it's a restaurant internet website it
costs money to get things going and it's
actually quite stressful to like watch
your bank balance
tick down as you hope your revenue and
profits are going up yeah how close did
you guys get to running out of money
because you guys had literally no
capital other than your IndieGoGo
campaign Nick that was fast
yeah I mean early days early couple
years I mean it was kind of what do we
think because for us a big piece of our
business is q4 so come around summer
time we even right now we place big
orders for the second half a year and so
pretty much every year for the first few
years we had no idea if we were gonna
sell through this inventory were buying
very very large POS which would deplete
a lot of the cash and then you'd have to
sell it otherwise you're stuck with
inventory and that's our business
and I so fortunately for us we actually
had the reverse issue where we would
sell out too quickly we didn't buy
enough which was a great problem to have
but where there was there times where
you were like I don't know if we're
gonna be able to make like we have to do
something in the next four days because
payrolls coming up we were very very
lean for the first year it was just me
and Kramer we did a million that year I
mean we had my mom was doing bookkeeping
or something but we should give her free
watches or something I can't remember
and it was very lean I mean really it
was like it was inventory and then it
was our website which we actually were
gonna launch on Magento then we heard
this thing called Shopify we got a quote
for 30 km Magento and they went to
Shopify got a better website for 2-grand
so we were just very lean it was like if
it's cheaper and we think that it's a
sustainable option like let's just go
that route and it turned out to be a
better route so the first year revenue
was a million and that was mostly from
to IndieGoGo campaigns right so to
indiegogo campaign basically launching
an ego game campaign did 200k and then
realized she'd we don't have a website
we got a relaunch and then we did
another hundred K on that and then the
rest of the year was just our own
e-commerce website and so how did you oh
and by the way up that 1 million do you
know how much was profit
I don't off the time I had to be honest
but probably yeah 300k I was 300k and
after that first year how are you able
to feel growth because you guys jumped
from like a million in revenue to seven
seven and then like what 27 to 37 30 and
then 30 to 60 to 80 now 200 yeah what
what helped that early growth you know
how were you able to jump from a million
to seven million yeah in just one year
in revenue yeah so we really focused we
really didn't spend any money on
marketing year one but kind of depleted
a lot of like we were doing
word-of-mouth and I had hit kind of a
certain capacity of it just wasn't
growing as fast as one of the business
to grow so we started spending money
we're looking for channels to spend
money on whether it was Instagram
Facebook Twitter at the time Twitter was
bigger than then Instagram Facebook
wasn't really proving out yet but for me
it just made the most sense and it
seemed to have like
the backend seemed to be you know
equally as built out as a like an
AdWords Google so for us started testing
there and found success early on and we
were able to convert customers at a
really low cost per acquisition for like
10 15 bucks and there just wasn't a lot
of it wasn't saturate at the time so but
I think the challenge back then that I
always like people are like oh you're so
lucky you were able to acquire customers
for so cheap that that is true but there
wasn't like it clear like everyone knows
Facebook's a great way to build a brand
now that wasn't known back then so we
had to kind of you know trial and error
in so many different places first time
we spent money on Twitter we spent money
on tabula and other areas and Facebook
proved to be the most successful when I
actually taught myself how to do it I
was running the ad so I really
understood what was right and what was
wrong we actually hired someone off of
Reddit to run it initially and then it
ended up bringing in a house but I think
the big you know way that for us the
scale was just acquiring customers for a
low cost so basically in 2014 this is
your second year Facebook had how many
Facebook at this time must have had
close to a billion users but how many
advertisers were there do you know I
don't remember off the top my head but I
believe it was it went it's 10 next yeah
so there just simply was not a lot of
people advertising on Facebook and one
of the early ones yeah and you was the
game plan just as long as we're
acquiring users we're gonna spend all of
our budget on pretty I mean for the most
part we didn't want to be overly salesy
but people love the brand we were I mean
yeah we were we were profitable on every
single order we still to this day being
bootstrapped we have to be profitable in
every single order that we get you know
I think some brands that are venture
backs are willing to lose money because
they're hoping to recoup that you know
six months or 12 months on the road for
us it was the day we acquire a customer
we need to make money otherwise we're
gonna go out of business so as long as
that was happening in any channel that
we're spending on and it was you know
supporting the what the brand
represented I think we were okay with it
and went that year that you guys did
seven million in revenue how many people
were working there at the time there's
probably like three or four maybe maybe
a couple
people part-time Wow yeah so someone was
just tweeted at me and it's actually a
good question to ask now which was
during your IndieGoGo campaign you were
able to get the money and then go and
buy the product how did that change how
did you ship to be more operationally
savvy to be able to have inventory at
all times you can negotiate with your
manufacturer on terms so now we put down
twenty to thirty percent and then we get
in that terms once shipped so there's
negotiations like that you don't have
that leverage early on but I mean if the
manufacturer wants your business then
hopefully they can give you terms we
have inventory planners now we're very
sophisticated and kind of mapping that
out and we have a line of credit to help
with some of these things but back then
it was we didn't want it over by
inventory so it was pre-orders and
people would come and buy inventory or
buy products on pre-orders and they'd be
willing to wait a month or two we ended
up pissing a lot of people off if it
would take longer than a month or two
but we were a startup and if they wanted
the product and they had to wait what
I'm amazed about is how you just said
you guys did so right now you guys are
gonna do 100 million dollars in revenue
with 34 full-time employees you did
seven million in revenue with you said
four full-time employees what tools were
you using to make this possible I mean
it sounds you must have had a lot of
automation I mean it just seems like one
of the most efficient businesses I've
ever heard of in my life sure I think
well for us another thing is you know
watches or one-size-fits-all generally
and Shopify is a big secret to be honest
through our success I mean so many
brands would launch on magenta or these
other shopping carts and it to do some
of the tools or the features that we do
abandoned cart or a pop-up or reviews I
mean they would have to pay thousands of
dollars and have developers involved I
mean for me it was like plug and play it
was click tested I'd do it all I mean I
was running the entire website on my own
essentially we paid it as developer two
grand to get the template up the
templates cost 150 bucks so I probably
overpaid on that and really it was just
me running the website and Facebook
instigating the Instagram we really
focused on social I mean we would
do you know the movement was always
about our community of people who backed
us from day one so we would always do
giveaways that every a thousand lights
we get or you know we'd offer discounts
or store credit if people were friends
so really focusing on the community your
first adopters to really spread the word
and the movement and we focus on a you
know again focused on something more
than just a watch we knew early days
that we couldn't just be posting
pictures and watches on Instagram no one
want to follow that so it's more of an
experience and a lifestyle and again I
think all you know great brands stand
for something more than just a physical
good amongst my friends who start
businesses around here and end up taking
a lot of money is that it seems like
they try to accomplish a lot at the same
time and in order to do that what they
what they do is they add in they add and
[__] that's probably unnecessary so
they'll think we should have this type
of social page because everyone else has
it or we need to have a blog because
everyone else has what we need to do
this and that and that and a lot of it's
unnecessary and it's kind of like the
80/20 rule where 20% of your effort
produces 80% of the percent of the
results and it's almost like you just
did that to the extreme does that sound
accurate I mean did you did your team it
was your team telling you like oh hey
it's going great let's expand a
sunglasses right now or let's expand to
this type of accessory or let's add this
thing or that thing if we've got this
state discipline I think early days it
was I was more obsessive of over you
know we knew what products we were
coming out with that was and it took a
long time the development cycle we
didn't have a designer in-house so we
knew it like you know coming out with
more product you took a while for us it
was how do we get more people to the
site that haven't heard about us whether
it's Facebook or Twitter or Instagram or
radio or whatever else it was so I was
obsessed over finding different
acquisition channels to bring traffic
you know I mean it's like a retail store
you don't have any walk through traffic
you're not gonna sell anything so for me
it was just getting cost-effective
traffic and people who are actually in
market for a watch so focused on finding
that and then also optimizing the
website with Shopify you have a lot of
leniency to do that so I was very
obsessed with not other watch brands but
other e-commerce players that I thought
were doing a really
job and seeing what tools they were
using what review tools or what
advertising channels and there's a bunch
of like chrome plugins that you can do
to see pretty much every script that's
on the side and know what they use and
I'd kind of go one by one and figure out
like what worked and what didn't it and
then just use my gut like if something
didn't make sense to me I I didn't do it
so it's just you gotta use your
intuition as an entrepreneur when things
make sense or do there was there was
some there was some like vendors that
would just charge ridiculous rates to
use their service and there's an
alternative that's you know ten times
less and we would often go with them and
find the same results so I'm gonna ask
you a couple more questions and then I'm
gonna go to my Twitter so it's at the
sampar I'll try to answer some of the
questions so tweet them at me now but in
a little bit I'm gonna interview one of
the founders of instacart which has
raised many hundreds of millions of
dollars and I believe you guys were
doing close to 30 or 40 million dollars
before you even had a lot in credit with
the bank but I know that you've had you
still do have lots of people wanting to
invest in you guys if you had to start
today do you think that you still could
have done this with with no finance
without any financing I think it would
be very tough I mean I think especially
in our space right like we're in our
space so it'd be hard to compete with us
and we've were spending on different
channels and we're working with we're
working with different influencers so
it's just hard to compete with what
we're already doing but I think if I
were to start over now having money to
be able to spend on knowing that
Facebook works knowing that influencer
marketing works knowing you know I need
an optimized website like there's
different ways to do it and I think
IndieGoGo and Kickstarter some of those
places are more saturated there's still
people who are raising money I think for
me if I were to do it again because I
haven't win under my belt so to speak I
would I would go and either take friends
and family money or an angel you know
investor I wouldn't go out just to go
raise money though because then you're
setting yourself for like extremely high
expectations potentially but I think
it's doable I think that the ways that I
built the brand on reddit and so forth
those may not work today but now you
have snapchat you have twitch you have
all these other
channels that I believe there's
opportunity and that that big brands are
overlooking because they don't have time
to invest it's not scalable yeah
Facebook is scalable TV is scalable but
reddit wasn't skilled well we don't even
do it anymore
maybe it works maybe it doesn't I don't
know but it's not scalable for us before
starting off and you have no money it's
a good way to generate ten fifteen
thousand dollars of cash and you so you
are able to get to low tens of millions
in revenue doing these somewhat hacky
things like Reddit I used it I mainly
used it year one your one and as it was
just wasn't well basically all the
communities of Reddit started to catch
on and like someone did this which on
and found out that I was doing this and
called me out and I got banned from
reddit so so that didn't work anymore
but yeah early days I mean when you're
on IndieGoGo in kitchens of people's
million millions of people on those
websites so I think it's important too
you have to leverage and get as many
people to that page to convert and the
more you convert the more sales you
generate their algorithm works in the
sense that you go to the popular page
and they send you out an email so really
for us the reason we want on IndieGoGo
is because we were able to generate our
own revenue even if it was ten fifteen
thousand dollars and then the IndieGoGo
system tool put us in an email we
generated 30 thousand dollars in a day
and then we got on the home page and so
I think for us it was just those little
things that no one else knew what to do
and that's really what helped us okay
and now you guys you guys are way beyond
just advertising on Facebook or doing
direct direct response ads you're on I
mean I hear you on every podcast I see
you personally on doing commercials on
TV how are those things working I mean
that's like a huge gap it seems like
like creating a Facebook ad it takes
literally a hundred dollars in 30
seconds yeah it's like it seems like
going to TVs just way different yeah
how's that how's that stuff going the
Baron entry is definitely more difficult
for something like TV you need a
produced spot and just buying ads and
testing you need capital to do that but
so we're in a place where we can go and
test that or test radio or podcast but
can you reveal how much it costs to
going to do it a nationally a national
commercial we're buying remnant so it's
like available spots I don't know off
the top my head though like what a
typical spot goes for I think it depends
on what
and what time and if then be a play
officer going on or what so but yeah
it's just been a strategy of testing
different channels and seeing what's
what's worked I moved on Pandora we've
done you know regular radio TV Direct
Mail I mean we've done literally
everything you can think about other
than billboards but eventually we're
Paul I do that too and so as are you
seeing results from the TV and podcast
ads if we're doing it and you see it
consistently we're seeing results great
all right I'm gonna answer some of these
questions from Twitter someone a couple
people actually asked about the margins
they're talking about a 300k a profit on
a million sales in new year one have
your margins been able to stay the same
or increase yeah I mean typically in
terms of just product margins typically
as you scale you're able to work with
your manufacturers to get better margins
so there was a question here about since
you guys were a first mover or one of
the early movers with Facebook and a lot
of the new direct response ads where do
you see what's the next frontier for
marketing it's hard I mean I'm I'm
really excited about twitch to be honest
that were you gonna put is that a bet
you'll may think we're doing some tests
there I don't fully understand the
ecosystem there yet but I think that
there's definitely I mean there was that
stat about I think ninja versus I don't
know maybe Drake or something and ninja
had more explain that to folks who don't
so ninja I believe is some it's like a
twitch video game streamer and then I
think it was going off of Drake's
Instagram and just saying that ninja had
more impressions more people that were
watching him in a given month or
whatever it was I don't remember the
exact step but those are things that I
think large companies are just unaware
of right now and I think there's still
arbitrage that you can go there and and
you know scale when no one else really
understands it I mean influencer
marketing when we started influencers
didn't know they could get paid to post
and we just said hey we'll pay you will
pay you so we'd spend $100 and then sell
10 watches and we're like okay we'll do
that all day as long as it's going and
then other brands come up and now you
can't spend $100 for anyone to post it's
way more iya thousands
that's crazy what's them can you reveal
the most expensive influence were you
paid uh I won't say who but we spent six
figures on one post what did you get
back from it not six figures so we only
have a few minutes left and a lot of
people are asking questions about what
you what what what what do you think you
should have done back when you're
starting that you didn't and I phrased
it a little bit differently but what's
one thing that we cover we haven't
talked about about your experience
without raising any funding to build a
big business what's what's something
that something that either a you wish
you would have known or something that
people often don't assume is the truth
about about that yeah I don't know
there's a specific thing I can give but
I think for me one of the things that I
did is I used LinkedIn and just networks
to go and like cold reach out to people
that I wanted to network with and I
figured that and honestly early days it
wasn't the CEOs because a lot of the
CEOs were busy either hiring people or
raising money like the CEOs that of the
brands that we're doing well weren't
really in the weeds as much so I went
after you know the VP of acquisition at
Dollar Shave Club or you know different
brands that I respected that we're doing
well and I would just network with them
and then get another referral and talked
to people who were really running
certain channels or whatever was talk to
director Viacom at whatever company was
and I think my network I'm in Los
Angeles and I'm not originally from LA
I'm from Valencia which is you know hour
and a half two hours away but living in
the heart of LA now has allowed me to go
and meet different founders and meet
different people within the companies
that have for sure movement as benefited
for we wouldn't be the brand we are
today if it wasn't for that network and
it wasn't I didn't have the network to
begin with I just offer someone I'd come
up with some clever you know subject
line on a LinkedIn and then offer to buy
him dinner a beer whatever was and go up
to people and sometimes I'd have bad
interactions but if I had a bad
interaction with someone I just kind of
brushed off and go to the next one so I
think that is
really crucial for entrepreneurs and
it's hard it's awkward but you have to
do it as an entrepreneur and I only have
two more questions which was so I'm sure
you guys have a ton of copycats now
right how are you gonna continue to win
those battles and and and stay unique
and continue growing yeah I mean I think
as long as people are copying us to
always be a step behind for us were the
innovators in terms of what our brain
represents who we work with I think the
people that we have the talent in Los
Angeles is huge being in LA there's not
only in our company a lot of talented
people but you have the influencers and
tastemakers that all live in Los Angeles
so I think another big piece too is like
I'm 27 so I'm a millennial and
understanding what social networks or
what products or trends is a really big
piece of the success of the company and
someone just tweeted at me and they
wanted to know because you didn't have
the ability to fall back on a large
venture funded bank account
can you tell one story where it was the
company was at a near-death moment so we
didn't have it we now have a VP senior
vice president of finance and we wanted
in it and just struggled with
understanding how like when cash comes
in and when it comes out and there was
just times where we they're smiling you
just really what you're doing this I
wasn't doing it but it was no one's
fault it's just we should have hired
someone earlier we just didn't know but
there was times where I think we almost
over bought an inventory and we would
have gone there's been a but there's
been so many times I can't even think of
all of them um yeah it's it's a
rollercoaster and we're about wrapped up
so but what's gonna happen next with
movement you guys were launching more
stuff where do you say what's your dream
and how are you gonna get there yeah I
mean for us we want to be we're already
a global brand we saw 160 countries
we're about 40 percent international
most of our business right now is
direct-to-consumer that's that was our
business model our strategy but the goal
is to become a global omni tail brand so
omni-channel brands so you know having
our own retail doors one day being in
different retailers as well I think as a
brand you need to be where a customer
where your customers want to buy you and
I think a lot of people get
caught up on just direct to consumer
direct to consumer it's a great way to
start a brand because you can you keep
all the data it's cost-effective if you
spend money on an acquisition channel
you're able to have all that data and
understand how to scale it but at the
end of the day if a customer shops on
Amazon or shops in Nordstrom you need to
be there if that's where they want to
buy you and otherwise you're missing out
in your competition competition might
take market share
fantastic well I think Jake you're gonna
be hanging out throughout the day yeah
absolutely so oh and there were actually
was one more question that I wanted to
ask you and I don't know you guys maybe
not you'll see some movement employees
walking around and you'll understand
this woman when you finally see them but
do you have to be totally yoked in order
to work at movement absolutely that's it
they had a guy at our dinner last night
who I swore he was the security guard we
said yeah we sent Ethan to negotiate our
lease contracts anything I was like he
was like I do marketing at movement I
was like oh I thought I was like I
legitimately thought your security this
guy was one of the biggest guys I've
ever seen in all five of their employees
were just jacked yeah we all we all we
all try and keep up with him but yeah
six four he wasn't always that big but
over the years he's he's grown so I
don't know maybe there's something in
the movement water
yeah like ping pong tables and stuff a
bit protein powder that's your that's
your perks yeah well all right Jake I
really appreciate you doing the next lot
Jake's will be hanging out all day so
you could ask him any questions
subdued anybody